[Musique]
mais 1933 dans toute l'allemagne
les étudiants nazis les chemises brunes
et la jeunesse hitlérienne rassemblent
et brûlent des livres par milliers des
oeuvres de littérature de philosophie et
de sciences partons flammes
hitler vient de déclarer la guerre à la
raison
[Musique]
les gens nous font passer pour des
ennemis de l'intelligence ans clame
hitler oui nous le sommes mais dans un
sens beaucoup plus profond que ne l'ont
jamais osé imaginer ces bourgeois
scientifique abrutis et vaniteux la
révolte de hitler contre l'intellect
s'inscrit dans une nouvelle religion une
religion consacré au mystère du sens et
de la race les anciennes croyances
seront remis à l'honneur déclare hitler
nous rétablirons toute la connaissance
secrets de la nature du divin de l'ain
forme du démoniaque
nous regretterons le vernis chrétiens et
nous retrouvons la religion de notre
race
la religion du sang dont parle hitler
ouvrira la voie à des millions de
meurtre pourtant la doctrine raciales
nazies n'est pas la création de hitler
ses racines se trouvent dans les
enseignements de la mystique germanique
et des doctrines de le culte
dans l'allemagne de la fin du 19e siècle
la tante de la mise en oeuvre des
promesses faites par le gouvernement est
grande avec la naissance du deuxième
reich allemand en 1871 est le
couronnement de l'empereur guillaume
premier l'avenir de l'allemagne semblait
assurée pourtant l'espoir romantique de
voir s'établir une nation comme pour le
d'ordre et de stabilité n'avait pas
réussi à se matérialiser
derrière la cérémonie médiévale à la
cour de l'empereur couvet le traumatisme
profond d'une révolution industrielle
des millions de paysans abandonnent
leurs terres et affluent vers les villes
les moyens d'existence des artisans et
des ouvriers sont balayées par la
production de masse une nouvelle classe
de financiers des industriels rivalisent
de puissance avec l'ancienne
aristocratie déjà le nouveau reich
allemand semble destiné au chaos et à la
division
mais ironie du sort l'unité tant
sollicitée par les allemands du rail
spiel ennemis mien trou sa base dans les
enseignements d'un anglais en 1897
l'empereur guillaume ii fait venir à sa
cour le célèbre écrivain anglais houston
stewart chamberlain son livre les
fondations du 19e siècle va inspirer
toute une génération de nationalistes
d'antisémite de mystique allemand et le
futur parti national socialiste
selon chamberlain la clé de l'histoire
de l'humanité réside dans la montée et
le déclin des races
chamberlain perçoit la race tonique
comme l'inspiratrice de la culture et de
toutes les vraies civilisation
[Musique]
la conscience allemande doit mener les
peuples à rien la suprématie raciale et
à la domination du monde écrit l'auteur
plus tard l'empereur écrira à
chamberlain
c'est dieu qui a envoyé votre livre
peuple allemand et vous en personne à
moi
[Musique]
chamberlain prône que l'affinité avec le
mystique prend ses racines profondes
dans le caractère à rien et il écrit que
tout mystique qui le veuille ou non est
un antisémite nez
dans la prusse de la fin du 19e siècle
les juifs best exclus du corps des
officiers de l'armée des professions
juridiques et d oran de la fonction
publique à travers l'europe
ces mesures avaient été défendue pendant
des siècles mettant en doute les
qualités morales et les loyauté
politique des non chrétiens
les écrits de chamberlain ajoute une
nouvelle dimension encore plus sinistre
à l'antisémitisme européen
les juifs ne sont plus considérés comme
une communauté religieuse mais comme des
étrangers et des ennemis dans les
doctrines raciales de chamberlain
l'objectif du peuple juif et de souiller
le sens des aryens en se mélangeant eux
selon l'écrivain il en résultera une
dégénérescence physique et morale et la
fin du rêve à rien de dominer le monde
la solution serait de purger l'allemagne
de ces juifs et de tous les étrangers
la clé de la domination allemande
résidera dans la création d'une religion
teutoniques une religion qui serait
fondée sur les mystères sacré du sang à
rien
pendant que les doctrines raciales de
chamberlain se répandent en allemagne
une religion fondée sur le sang a déjà
pris corps en autriche au début du 20e
siècle les autrichien d'origine
allemande se considère comme un peuple
assiégé longtemps gouverneurs et
administrateurs du grand empire
austro-hongrois
ils sont devenus une minorité dans un
état dominée par des peuples slaves
les fonctionnaires doivent savoir parler
le tchèque et l'allemand les prêtres
tchèque se voit attribuer un grand
nombre de paroisses allemande la langue
et la culture allemande semble en danger
de mort
aux yeux de nombreux austro-allemand
l'église catholique supporte pleinement
les intérêts slave
il en résulte une haine profonde
vis-à-vis d'une religion qui apparaît à
la fois hostile et traîtresse
[Musique]
le mécontentement profond du peuple
allemand d'autriche fini par engendrer
un puissant mouvement pan germanistes
dont le but est de réunir tous les
allemands au sein d'une seule
mère-patrie
dans les rangs de ce nouveau mouvement
nombreux sont ceux qui désillusionné par
le christianisme pause que les allemands
doivent retourner à la religion de leurs
ancêtres
le culte des dieux nordiques et les lois
primaire de la nature la doctrine selon
laquelle la pureté du sang ouvrira la
voie à un âge d'or de la suprématie
allemande trouve ça plus nobles
expression dans les enseignements d'un
renégat l'ancien moines cisterciens jürg
lens lens grand maître de l'ordre et
eric des nouveaux templiers bref une
doctrine étrange qu'il appelle théologie
[Musique]
dans un passé lointain les atlantes et
un quatrième race racines de la création
s'était scindée en une espèce pure et
une espèce animale des millénaires plus
tard les hommes dieu a rien de la
cinquième race racines s'étaient croisés
avec l'espèce animale
il en résulte un déclin catastrophique
et la quasi perte des pouvoirs
psychiques des aryens
lens se croient qu'en imposant de
strictes lois raciales les anciennes
tribus germaniques avait purifier leur
sang retrouvant les traces de la nature
divine des à rien il enseigne que ces
lois qui avait été détruite par le
christianisme doivent être rétablis
[Musique]
après plusieurs générations il renaîtra
une race humaine supérieur l'homme dieu
destiné à régner sans partage sur le
monde
la vienne cosmopolite avec son passage
deux peuples et de cultures horrifie
your glass
pour lui le chaos du monde moderne
représente une lutte finale
un combat entre les races blonde avec
leurs grâces solide 200 à rien et les
sous-hommes
ce dont le sens est dominé par le sang
des bêtes
dès 1905 lands publie sa prescription du
salut raciale dans la revue populaire
aux stars à sa propre publication
périodique selon lance les classes
dominantes allemande la race la plus
pure de tous les allemands doivent être
encouragés à se reproduire
la polygamie est un programme sélectif
de reproduction humaine permettrait de
reconquérir la pureté du sang quant aux
classes sociales populaires par
définition plus pauvres et inférieures
elles doivent être réduites à
l'esclavagé ou stériliser le mariage
entre les allemands et les peuples
inférieurs doivent être prohibé les
contrevenants devait être puni par une
privation de nourriture
le juif l'ennemi le plus mortel des
aryens serait utilisé comme bête de
somme
déporté à madagascar ou incinérés la
revue ostara de youg's est édité dans de
modestes locaux viennois est envoyé dans
tout le monde germanophone en 1909 lens
reçoit la visite d'un misérable peintre
de 20 ans
adolf hitler était la recherche
d'anciens numéros il tient beaucoup à
compléter sa collection
lorsqu'ils emménagent dans un nouveau
logement un foyer pour hommes au numéro
27 de lamelles de munch traceux il
emporte avec lui sa collection de stars
à soit plus de 50 numéros comme la
plupart de ses compatriotes
austro-allemand hitler considéré le
judaïsme comme une religion étrangère
des écrits de youg's
il apprend désormais que les allemands
et les juifs sont deux races en guerre
plus tard hitler écrire à la
conglomération raciale de la capitale
impériale ma répugné la ville semblait
incarner l'infamie gracial
[Musique]
en mai 1913 hitler qui deviennent pour
mener une nouvelle vie dans la mère
patrie ian moore
[Musique]
la cité bavaroise de munich dans
laquelle adolf hitler alors âgé de 24
ans mène une vie précaire est secoué par
des agitations nationaliste et
antisémite et ici tout comme à vienne
pour l'y faire des sociétés secrètes et
des cercles occultes
attisé par les incertitudes du monde
moderne
pour les membres instruit de
l'aristocratie les enseignements de your
glass et d'ésotérique allemands sont
infiniment rassurant les forces de la
démocratie et du capitalisme
les agents de change owni sont
considérés comme les sinistres invention
des races inférieures en particulier des
juifs
on aspire fortement à la guerre une
guerre qui rétablirait l'unité l'ordre
et l' empire your glantz avait prédit à
la suite de la jubilation des hommes
dieux libéré nous irons conquérir toute
la planète
le feu sera nourri jusqu'à ce que des
étincelles jaillissent des canons des
cuirassé allemand et que l'ordre soit
créé
le 1er août 1914 sur la place odéon de
munich la guerre si longtemps attendue
par les nationalistes allemands est
proclamée à une foule en liesse dans la
foule en délire se trouve
adolf hitler
[Musique]
trois jours après la déclaration de
guerre hitler demande l'autorisation
d'intégrer un régiment bavarois il dit
alors ainsi commença pour moi comme pour
tous les allemands le temps le plus
inoubliable et le plus sublime de toute
mon existence terrestre après huit
semaines d'exercice hitler est envoyé au
front avec le 16e régiment d'infanterie
de réserve de bavière
il livre sa première bataille à ypres
pendant son premier jour de combats ses
exploits en tant que soldat de première
ligne lui valent d'être nommé estafette
de l'état major du régiment le jour
suivant
hitler souple fils y est commandant en
second pris dans un déluge de feu
cet exploit lui vaut une promotion au
grade de caporal et il est décoré de la
croix de fer de seconde classe
durant les quarante cinq mois qu'ils
passent au front avec son régiment qui
livrera 36 batailles majeures hitler se
fait remarquer pour son courage et sa
ferveur patriotique
les officiers ne tarissent pas d'éloges
sur lui l'un d'entre eux le qualifiera
de soldats extrêmement consciencieux
efficace et courageux pour les camarades
de hitler l'estafette dévoué qu'ils
appellent l'autrichien semble distante
c'est seulement lorsqu'ils commencent à
parler de la nouvelle ère à venir dit
les révèle sa passion enflammée pour
l'allemagne après la guerre il est
convaincu que les austro allemand seront
réunis dans la mère patrie et que la
grande allemagne purgera les éléments
ration étrangers et la démocratie érigé
par ces derniers avec ses arguments
hitler exercent une grande force de
persuasion sur ses camarades à cela dira
que personne ne pouvait se détourner de
la forte personnalité d'hitler et que
ses opinions était acceptée par la
plupart des soldats à l'été 1918 fait
rarissime pour un caporal hitler reçoit
la croix de fer de première classe pour
les combats exceptionnel qu'il a livrée
pendant ces quatre années passées au
front
[Musique]
le 13 octobre 1918 à ypres à 6
kilomètres du lieu où il avait accompli
sa première mission en 1914
hitler est blessé dans une attaque au
gaz devenu presque aveugle il est
transféré dans un hôpital militaire en
allemagne
pendant que adolf hitler se remettent
lentement de ses blessures
les événements s'accélèrent dans le
monde extérieur
une offensive massive des alliés menace
de percer les lignes allemandes
de plus la ville de berlin est paralysé
par des grévistes qui réclament la paix
et la démocratie dans l'intérêt de la
patrie au conseil à l'empereur de
solliciter la paix et de reconnaître un
gouvernement démocratique
le 9 novembre à berlin dans la tourmente
d'une grève générale
l'empereur abdique le deuxième reich
allemand connaît une fin abrupte et
dramatique
[Musique]
le pays plonge dans l'anarchie
adolf hitler toujours sous les drapeaux
reprend du service dans l'armée d'abord
dans son régiment à munich puis comme
garde d'un camp de prisonniers de guerre
à 100 km de la ville alors que ces
prisonniers attendent leur rapatriement
hitler ressasse l'humiliation de
l'armistice pour lui comme pour beaucoup
de ses camarades l'armée le peuple
allemand ont été poignardés dans le dos
par les démocrates
les marxistes et surtout les juifs la
haine grandit en moi j'avais la haine
contre les responsables de ce diktat
cela avait scellé mon destin ai je
décidé de m'engager dans la politique
écrit hitler entre mars 1919 lorsqu'ils
retournent dans une unité à munich et
mars 1920 où il sera finalement libéré
de l'armée
hitler et la bavière ont changé pendant
que la bavière se transforme tour à tour
en fief communiste puis au foyer de
contre révolutionnaire nationaliste
hitler devient un homme de confiance de
l'armée il rejoint le parti ouvrier
allemand alors encore insignifiant et
découvre son talent d'orateur
bien qu'il soit toujours à la solde de
l'armée bavaroise hitler devient le chef
de propagande du parti
la préoccupation essentielle de hitler l
expulsion des juifs de l'allemagne
hitler avait appris de your glass que le
but de la race juive était de saboter la
mission du peuple a rien dans le monde
cette doctrine était déjà fait venir à
de nombreux membres du parti ouvrier
allemand
le parti avait été une émanation directe
de la société tulle et une loge munich
oise pangermaniste et antisémites
le symbole de la société thulé et la
swastika
le parti renommée depuis le nsdap parti
national socialiste des travailleurs
allemands développent une idéologie à
part entière le modelage des croyances
raciale de hitler en une vision du monde
cohérent et global résultera de son
étroite amitié avec trois hommes alfred
rosenberg disciple de houston stewart
chamberlain dietrich écarte un proche
associé de la société thulé et rudolf
hess le futur numéro deux du troisième
reich tous sont des mystiques convaincu
alfred rosenberg un allemand de la
baltique avait découvert le livre de
chime berlin les fondations du 19e
siècle à l'âge de 17 ans déjà
son expérience personnelle de la
révolution russe et la guerre civile qui
s'ensuivit semble confirmer à ses yeux
les doctrines raciales de chamberlain
l'aristocratie régnant en russie que
rosenberg croit être d'origine aériennes
avaient été chassés par les peuples
slaves inférieur soulevé est menée par
les juifs pour rosenberg le bolchévisme
en russie et la nouvelle démocratie en
allemagne font tous deux partie du
complot juif mondial
son inspiration et mains d'une oeuvre
mystérieuse les protocoles des sages de
sion
[Musique]
apporter en allemagne par
l'intermédiaire d'immigrants russes
fuyant la révolution les protocoles
prétendait être un projet juifs secret
visant à dominer le monde
en réalité c'est un leurre qui a été
rédigée au 19e siècle par la police
secrète du tsar russe à munich
alfred rosenberg rencontre le célèbre
journaliste éditeur et poète antisémite
dietrich écarte ses eckhart qui
introduit rosenberg dans le cercle
d'adolphe hitler entre 1920 et 1923
écarté rosenberg travaille
inlassablement au service de hitler et
du parti grâce à rosenberg hitler prend
connaissance des protocoles et des
travaux de houston stewart chamberlain
rosenberg prononcent des discours à la
société thulé et publie loeffel tischer
bo basterds le journal du parti qui
avant appartenait à la société tulle et
dans les pages du bo basterds rosenberg
publiera une série des textes des
protocoles des sages de sion
afin de lever des fonds pour le journal
du parti
dietrich et cartes introduit hitler dans
les milieux influents qui soutiendront
progressivement le parti nazi naissant
pendant ce temps dans la maison d'un
riche industriel berlinois hitler
développe son talent oratoire
[Musique]
dietrich et cartes introduites l'air
chez des amis influents en le présentant
comme le jeune mais si de l'allemagne
ainsi hitler devient le premier disciple
de écarte rudolf hess est tout comme
hitler un héros de guerre
désillusionnés et gris en mai 1920 et
quart temps mais n'est-ce assisté à son
premier meeting du parti nazi et le fait
rencontrer hitler pour la première fois
s croyait voir en hitler le sauveur de
l'allemagne longtemps prophétisé par les
cercles ésotériques allemand l'homme
fort d'en haut
l'homme qui mènerait les peuples
allemand à l'aube d'un rachat rien
millénaire
en 1923 une grande partie de l'
idéologie raciale d'hitler a pris corps
les préjugés de sa jeunesse avait forgé
une doctrine imprégné du mysticisme à
rien sa foi dans sa mission salvatrice
s'approfondit de plus en plus ainsi
après avoir assisté un rassemblement
nationaliste près de bayeux ruth hitler
fait un pèlerinage personnel à byron se
trouve la maison dans laquelle richard
wagner l'idole d'adolphe hitler
depuis l'adolescence à passer en partie
les dernières années de sa vie
la maison appartenant toujours à la
famille wagner est devenue un sanctuaire
virtuels étant jeune homme hitler
vénérait wagner comme le prophète
suprême du peuple allemand dans ses
opéras et ses écrits antisémites hitler
voit désormais la confirmation suprême
de ses convictions les plus intimes
tout comme les mystiques allemand wagner
croyez les juifs incapable d'une
quelconque spiritualité
car une partie de l'humanité descendent
être supérieur tandis que les juifs sont
les descendants de grands singes
dans le drame parsifal de wagner qui se
fonde sur des légendes médiévales des
chevaliers du saint graal parsifal est
un christ à rien wagner avait lui même
décrit le saint graal comme un symbole
de la pureté du sang une mise en garde
contre la pollution raciale pour le
peuple allemand
après avoir fait le tour du domicile de
wagner hitler demande la permission de
se rendre seuls sur la tombe du
compositeur il reviendra empreint d'une
grande émotion et déclare j'ai fait de
parsifal une religion la fille de wagner
et eva s'est mariée avec le mystique
anglais houston stewart chamberlain
chamberlain dit ait l'air d'un coup vous
avez changé l'état de mon âme
le fait que l'allemagne ait donné
naissance à un hitler au moment où elle
en avait le plus besoin est une preuve
de sa vitalité
un mois après sa visite à byron hitler
tente pour la première fois de prendre
le pouvoir
le putsch du 9 novembre 1923 au cours
duquel les chemises brunes de iter
accompagné d'autres groupes
paramilitaires nationaliste et c'est de
prendre le contrôle du gouvernement
bavarois est un cuisant échec
mais l'arrestation le jugement et
l'emprisonnement de hitler fond de
l'obscur agitateurs autrichien un martyr
politique
c'est dans la prison forteresse de
landsberg que les croyances de hitler
fondée sur une fois mystique dans le
destin de la race allemande prendront un
nouveau caractère soi-disant
scientifique
le compagnon de cellule de hitler rudolf
hess avait été pendant un temps
étudiants en sciences économiques à
l'université de munich
là il avait été fortement influencée par
les enseignements de l'ancien général et
géopoliticien carlao soffer la
géopolitique est une science nouvelle
se définissant par l'étude approfondie
des populations et des ressources
naturelles qui tente d'expliquer
l'histoire politique des nations haus of
her enseigné que les besoins vitaux de
l'allemagne ne seraient pas satisfaits
par la prise de colonies d'outre-mer
mais par une expansion sur le continent
européen pourra aux surfeurs le destin
national de l'allemagne reposait sur une
expansion à l'est la doctrine du lait
benz comme le droit à un espace vital
pour le peuple allemand devient la
pierre angulaire de l'idéologie du parti
national socialiste qui a seulement
surpassé en importance par les principes
ratio
pendant que hitler languissent en prison
il découvre également l'eugénisme un
mouvement scientifique internationale le
principe de l'eugénisme et que la
dégénérescence et le déclin de la race
humaine sont imminents ainsi selon cette
doctrine non seulement les maladies
comme la tuberculose ou l'épilepsie ce
serait héréditaire mais aussi les
faiblesses et puissance morale et
mentale de l'homme
[Musique]
beaucoup sont convaincus que le
croisement des différents peuples
produite une progéniture dégénéré
comme des couches populaires ont
davantage d'enfants que les classes
sociales supérieures nombre d'éminents
scientifiques et médecins redoutent dans
le futur un d'éclat désastre de la race
pour éviter cette calamité il affirme
que les individus valables doivent être
encouragés à se reproduire les races
inférieures stérilisés pour le bien de
tous
[Musique]
originaire d'angleterre l'eugénisme
s'est répandu en allemagne jusqu'à
devenir la base de l'hygiène raciale du
troisième reich en 1923
fritz lang devient le premier
professeurs à enseigner l'hygiène
raciale à l'université de munich
il est le co auteur d'un manuel influent
éléments de génétique humaine et
d'hygiène raciale que hitler étudie
minutieusement en prison à landsberg
2 dont il trouve les éléments
scientifiques de la quête mystique
d'ésotérique pour une hiérarchie des
races fritz lang affirme qu'il existe
une hiérarchie claire entre les races et
entre les individus
ainsi certains seraient destinés à être
des esclaves d'autres ce rennais pour
dominer le monde
[Musique]
après avoir purgé neuf mois de sa peine
d'emprisonnement de cinq ans hitler est
libéré de landsberg en décembre 1924
selon ses propres mots son
emprisonnement a été une université aux
dépens de l'état il a posé les jalons de
son idéologie
en rédigeant mein kampf son testament
politique
[Musique]
dans ce livre ickler décrit l'idéologie
de l'état que le parti devra construire
l'état n'a qu'un but qui est la
préservation des races humaines
cette connaissance lui confère
l'obligation suivant la volonté
éternelle qui gouverne ce monde de
favoriser la victoire du meilleur et du
plus fort et d'exiger la subordination
des mauvais et des faibles
[Musique]
hitler quoique la science l'art et même
la raison humaine doivent servir la
volonté de la nature et la nature
insiste-t-il
et fondamentalement aristocratique
[Musique]
ayant retenu la leçon du putsch manqué
de 1923 hitler engage le parti nazi à
prendre le pouvoir par des moyens
démocratiques
pendant ce temps il met en place un état
fantôme reposant sur deux strict
principe hiérarchique
ceux là même qui ont été longtemps prôné
par les cercles ésotériques est
désormais soutenu par la doctrine de
l'hygiène raciale
[Musique]
dans chaque sphère de la vie il doit y
avoir un chef qui détient les pouvoirs
absolue pour gouverner ses subordonnés
chacun doit une obéissance aveugle à son
propre chef au sommet de la hiérarchie
nazie se trouve
adolf hitler le grand fureur le guide
suprême
l'autorité qui détient tous les pouvoirs
[Musique]
dans l'idéologie mystique du national
socialisme le führer a été choisi par
les lois de la nature elle-même
il est la plus haute expression de l'âme
de la race
pour hitler l'unique mission d'un chef
suprême
c'est de libérer les émotions des masses
allemande de ramener à la surface leur
foi inébranlable dans la passe et le
sang et patates
[Applaudissements]
compellent et lambert ancien
international public aucune
[Applaudissements]
la route est glissante population la
roma on s est vraiment excellent bateau
les commissaires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
départ très bien sûr un sou qu'on se le
dise je fus rose les dépenses des
ménages il rêve
elles et ont dopé les partisans des deux
groupes
désolé une promenade sainte rose ne
réfléchit pas s'ils seront longues
l'hymne national au sujet de vérone
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
des fleurs
[Applaudissements]
pour beaucoup de médecins et
scientifiques du mouvement pour
l'hygiène raciale
le triomphe de adolf hitler et le
triomphe de la science le journal de
l'eugénisme publié par l'hygiéniste
raciale vritz l'aisne ce célèbre ce
qu'il appelle le nouvel âge de la
révolution raciale et biologiques
lentz écrit la volonté du führer c'est
que les exigences de l'hygiène raciale
soit immédiatement mis en application
c'est le début d'une voie qui mènera à
une stérilisation de masse à des
meurtres et au génocide
le 14 juillet 1933 le gouvernement nazi
adopte la loi pour la prévention des
enfants génétiquement malsain la loi
autorise la stérilisation d'individus
déclaré incurable et susceptibles de
transmettre leur tarde à leur
descendance
en application de la loi des comités
d'experts en génétique ordonneront la
stérilisation de plus de 400 mille
personnes
les causes les plus communes seront la
faiblesse d'esprit la schizophrénie et
l'épilepsie et l'alcoolisme avec la
coopération du corps médical le peuple
allemand devrait être purgé de tout
tares héréditaires
le programme d'eugénisme nazis doit
désormais s'atteler à la question de la
pureté raciale mais le socle idéologique
est déjà posée en mars 1933
lees à et les ss boycottent les magasins
juifs
en avril des lois interdisent aux juifs
de devenir fonctionnaire et d'exercer
des professions juridiques
par la suite une nouvelle loi interdit
aux juifs d'enseigner dans les
universités le but d'exclure les juifs
de la vie sociale et culturelle de
l'allemagne en septembre 1935 le
programme d'eugénisme est étendue pour
isoler biologiquement les juifs
hitler a tiré de la mystique germanique
une théorie distinctive est terrifiante
selon lui le juif est un sous-homme la
créature d'un autre dieu il vient d'une
autre branche de la race humaine
[Musique]
la loi pour la protection du sang et de
l'honneur allemand interdit les mariages
entre les aryens et les juifs
c'est une mesure qui avait déjà été
exigée par les cercles ésotériques
germanique au tournant du siècle la
catégorisation un juif et un an juif
revenait aux scientifiques du mouvement
pour l'hygiène raciale
[Musique]
à la fin 2009 135 les éléments clés du
programme d'eugénisme sont en place la
campagne de stérilisation est en cours
les lois raciales protégeant le sang
allemand de la pollution raciale sans
vigoureusement renforcée même les
mariages entre à rien sont sujets à des
contrôles stricts
les deux partenaires sont soumis à des
analyses décelant les maladies
héréditaires
les plans pour la prochaine étape de la
campagne de hitler visant à améliorer la
race allemande sont déjà en cours de
préparation
lors d'un rassemblement du parti nazi
hitler déclare si l'allemagne progrès un
million d'enfants par an et que nous y
tenions 700 à 800 milles personnes
faibles cela se traduirait finalement
par un renforcement de notre puissance
en 1935 à nuremberg hitler tito
reichsführer gerhard wagner responsable
des questions de santé que dans le cas
d'une guerre il ré examinerait la
question de l'euthanasie et la mettrait
en application
hitler pense pouvoir contenir plus
facilement l'opposition de l'église
chrétienne en temps de guerre les au
début de 1939 l'état national socialiste
est tellement fort qu aucun délai n'est
nécessaire en mai hitler demande à karl
brandt commissaire du reich à la santé
publique de nommer un comité consultatif
pour élaborer un programme visant à tuer
les enfants handicapés pour garantir le
secret total de l'opération
hitler charge sa chancellerie
d'administrer le programme
le régime a déjà tenté de faire accepter
au peuple allemand les mesures de
jeunisme dans des exercices de
mathématiques il est demandé aux enfants
de calculer le coût des handicapés et
des malades mentaux
l'un d'eux questionne la construction
d'un asile de fous coûte 6 millions de
marks
combien de logements peuvent être
construits avec des sommes investies
dans les asiles
[Musique]
le 18 août la chancellerie allemande
diffuse une circulaire les enfants âgés
jusqu'à 3 ans attardé ou souffrant de
difformités doivent être répertoriés par
les sages femmes ou de médecin puis un
questionnaire complet décrivant leur
handicap devra être remplie
[Musique]
trois médecins évaluent les formulaires
tournée marquant d'un plus les enfants
devant mourir hesdin - ceux qui peuvent
rester en vie aucun enfant n'est
examinée par les médecins
dans plus de 30 mx spécialisés les
enfants sélectionnés sont tués par
injection mortelle absorption de
sédatifs ou privation de nourriture
[Musique]
on explique que leur mort est due à des
causes naturelles en l'espace de deux
ans le programme d'euthanasie touche des
enfants âgés jusqu'à 12 ans
on
adolf hitler dit l'homme devient dieu
ceux qui ne voient dans le national
socialisme
rien de plus qu'un mouvement politique
ne savent presque rien à son sujet c'est
bien plus qu'une religion c'est la
volonté de créer un homme nouveau
[Musique]
pendant que les autorités médicales
allemandes se consacre pleinement à
plonger le pays de ces éléments un pur
la reproduction des forces de la nation
est en cours
chaque membre de la ss est soigneusement
sélectionnés pour sa perfection physique
et la pureté de son sens tenus par des
serments d'allégeance et des rites
mystique les ss ne peuvent se marier
qu'avec des femmes dont les ancêtres
sont de souche germanique
ainsi ils sont destinés à devenir sur
plusieurs générations
un réservoir du sang à rien le plus pur
[Musique]
le clan ss doit devenir une aristocratie
raciale un clan dont la mission sera de
régner sur les provinces orientales
en septembre 1939 hitler lens s'est armé
contre la pologne
[Musique]
il a déjà défini ses objectifs s'étant
plutôt l'est sera notre grand champ
d'expérimentation là-bas émergera un
nouvel ordre social européen avait il
dit les paysans polonais devront d'être
dépossédés à leurs places seront
installés des allemands de pure souche
sélectionner ceux là seront à leurs
administrés par la ss les polonais des
régions annexées par l'allemagne sont
concentrés dans une réserve appelé
gouvernement général les enfants
polonais supposé avoir du sens à rien
sont enlevés et envoyé en allemagne afin
de servir de réserve pour la
préservation de la pureté de la race les
juives des territoires occupés sont
concentrés dans des ghettos urbains à
l'intérieur du gouvernement général les
groupes d'intervention spéciale les
einsatzgruppen des ss ont l'ordre
d'assassiner l'intelligentsia et les
personnes les plus influentes de pologne
ils ont aussi été instruits dans le but
d'ouvrir une nouvelle phase dans le
programme d'euthanasie tuer les
individus jugés inaptes au travail ou à
la reproduction en pologne et dans les
régions de l'allemagne près de la
frontière polonaise des milliers de
malades des hôpitaux psychiatriques sont
enlevés et assassinés
conduite par une équipe de conseillers
médicaux la chancellerie de hitler a
méticuleusement évaluer le nombre de
personnes devant être traités dans le
programme d'euthanasie
ils ont conclu que sur 1000 allemand 10
étaient des malades mentaux 5
intégreront un hôpital psychiatrique
l'un d'entre eux devra mourir
[Musique]
selon les calculs du comité 65 à 75
mille personnes devront être tué la
méthode retenue consiste à les gaz et
dans des chambres prévues à cet effet
une procédure suggérer par le
département médico-légal de la police
civile à la chancellerie la section
responsable pour le programme
d'euthanasie est basé au numéro 4 tirs
cartonne strassen plus tard au vu de
cette adresse elle sera connue sous
l'appellation t4
à l'été 40 pendant la conquête allemande
de l'europe de l'ouest
les rumeurs de mort mystérieuse dans les
hôpitaux psychiatriques allemand
grandissent dans l'opinion publique
craignant pour leur vie
de plus en plus de personnes âgées
refuse d'entrer dans des maisons de
retraite
mais le programme des 4 étend son champ
d'action
[Musique]
les passions de certains hôpitaux et des
asiles sont bientôt assimilés aux
prisonniers atteints de maladie mentale
au début de 1941
les autorités du reich ordonne que tous
les patients juifs des hôpitaux
psychiatriques et allemand soient tués
les meurtriers de la section t4 certains
s'y de précurseur à la future campagne
d'extermination raciale annoncé par
hitler la solution finale
en 1934 hitler avait décrit la croisade
qui serait lancée contre les peuples
slaves de l'union soviétique d'aucune
manière ne pourront éviter le combat
final entre les idéaux ratio de
l'allemagne et les idéaux de masse des
peuples slaves
nous devrons mener cette bataille elle
nous ouvrira la porte vers une maîtrise
permanente du monde le nom choisi pour
l'invasion de l'urss et opération
barbarossa dans des légendes du
moyen-âge ravivées par les cercles
occultes allemand l'empereur barberousse
qui repose sous une montagne se
réveillera un jour et lâchera la
puissance allemande dans une fureur de
conquête
pour les peuples slaves de russie adolf
hitler planifie un monde cauchemardesque
des esclavages de masse et des mesures
hygiéniques drastiques
nous sommes obligés de dépeupler c'est
une partie essentielle de notre mission
si nous voulons préserver le peuple
allemand
nous devrons développer une technique de
dépeuplement
[Applaudissements]
en vue de la stérilisation futur de
dizaines de millions de slaves
les médecins allemands essaie de
développer des rayons x et des
techniques chirurgicales pour un
programme génique de masse à l'est
cependant pour les juifs soviétiques
hitler a prévu leur extermination pure
et simple
la guerre en russie devra servir de
couverture pour un génocide d'une
ampleur inimaginable
le 10 octobre 1941 le maréchal von drais
nos prend le commandement des divisions
armés dans la sphère orientale le soldat
n'est pas qu'un simple combattants
agissant selon les règles de la guerre
mais le fervent partisan d'une
implacable idéologie raciale
pour cette raison les soldats doivent
faire preuve d'une bonne compréhension
de la nécessité d'infliger une sévère
mais juste rédemption au sous-hommes
juifs à chaque groupe d'armées est
affecté une unité ss d'actions spéciales
les einsatzgruppen ne sont responsables
que devant heinrich himmler le
reichsführer dss au début de l'opération
barbarossa himmler confie le führer a
ordonné la solution finale de la
question juive et nous les ss devons
exécuter cet ordre
le raisonnement de himmler est un
mélange terrifiant de mysticisme et de
sciences devenu entre temps le socle de
l'idéologie nazie
les juifs sont les ennemis éternels de
la race allemande et doivent être
exterminés
si nous manquons de détruire la base
biologique de la communauté juive
alors un jour elle détruira le peuple
allemand
pour réaliser la solution finale à l'est
les nazis procède à des exécutions de
masse en automne 1941 les juifs
d'allemagne d'autriche et de
tchécoslovaquie sont déportés vers les
terres conquises en union soviétique les
meurtres à grande échelle à l'est et son
dégoût personnel pour les exécutions de
masse
ammann himmler à trouver une solution
alternative d'extermination dans les
hôpitaux psychiatriques allemand et au
sein de l'unité t4 on a déjà réfléchi à
une autre méthode d'élimination de masse
en août 1941 le t4 a atteint le nombre
de meurtres que son comité de médecins
avaient jugé nécessaire plus de 90 mille
malades mentaux ont été tuées dans les
hôpitaux allemands dont 71 milles dans
les chambres à gaz des hôpitaux mais des
rumeurs circulent sur le programme t4 et
le 3 août
monseigneur von galen évêque de man ster
dénonçons cher ces assassinats
trois semaines plus tard hitler ordonne
l'arrêt du programme
mais l'unité t4 n'est pas dissoute en
réalité elle continue dans la plus
grande discrétion à tuer les détenus des
camps de concentration jugés inaptes au
travail ainsi que des juifs des tziganes
et d'autres ennemis de la race aryenne
dans le jargon ss ils reçoivent un
traitement spécial les prisonniers
devant mourir sont sélectionnés par des
commissions itinérantes du t4 jusqu'à la
construction de bâtiment spécialement
conçu pour l'extermination de masse le
t4 fait en sorte que les condamnés
soient envoyés dans les chambres à gaz
des hôpitaux psychiatriques seulement
bientôt la collusion scellé entre le t4
et les ss dot adolf hitler d'une
nouvelle arme pour sa guerre
d'extermination raciale ensemble le t4
et les ss construiront les camps de la
mort prévue à cet effet
à l'été 1941 heinrich himmler ordonne
l'agrandissement du camp de
concentration d'auschwitz en y faisant
ajouté un centre d'extermination
la méthode de gaza j'ai testé sur 600
prisonniers de guerre russes et 200
malades en octobre alfred rosenberg
devenu entre-temps reichsführer des
territoires occupés à l'est invitent le
t4 a assisté à la liquidation des juifs
confinés dans les ghettos polonais ils
demandent une assistance dans la
reconstruction de l'est et ceux qu'il
appelle les bâtiments et équipements
nécessaires pour le gazage la courroie
de transmission entre rosenberg et la ss
et adolf eichmann c'est un ice man que
himmler avait confié l'anéantissement
d'un peuple tout entier
le supérieur deichmann reinhardt
heydrich est chargé de coordonner les
opérations
la décision de construire des camps
d'extermination doté de chambres à gaz
dans les territoires occupés à l'est est
prise en octobre 1941 le même mois
l'immigration des juifs d'allemagne vers
des pays étrangers est interdite car
selon les propres mots d'aldrich
l'europe doit être purgée des juifs
d'est en ouest
le premier camp de la mort est achevé à
chelmno en décembre 1941 les camps de
travail dahouche vite maïdanek et
treblinka sont transformés en camps
d'extermination
les chambres à gaz des hôpitaux
psychiatriques allemands sont démontés
et remontés à belzec treblinka et
sobibor
le personnel du des cadres suit les
convois tous continuent de recevoir leur
salaire de la chancellerie privé de
adolf hitler
[Musique]
depuis le tournant du siècle les dogmes
scientifique de l'organisme et les
fantaisies aryenne des milieux occultes
germaniques ont progressivement
fusionnées en une seule doctrine de
suprématie et d'extermination raciale
[Musique]
dès lors dans les camps de la mort les
techniques inventé par le corps médical
du reich sont mises en pratique pour
détruire un ennemi des aryens identifiés
par les mystiques
[Musique]
en 1933 hitler avait présenté à ses
partisans
un dilemme crucial pour notre peuple la
religion est une affaire capitale tout
dépend de savoir s'il restera fidèle à
la religion judéo-chrétienne et à la
morale servile de la pitié ou s'il aura
une fois nouvelle forte héroïque en un
dieu immanent à la nature à la nation
même en un dieu indiscernable de son
destin et de son sens en choisissant la
doctrine du sens au nom de la pureté
raciale
adolf hitler et ses disciples transforme
l'europe et l'urss en un vaste champ de
souffrance d'horreur et de mort
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
o o